this Hollywood babble-on with your hosts
Kevin Smith and Ralph Garman go full
Ralph I'm gonna go full Ralph normally
it's just the tip but now take it to
those massive [ __ ] balls
stuff the balls in with it before I get
Florida go balls deep is Jocelyn Dwyer
out there tonight she here - Jocelyn E
around where's ray V wave your hand that
hi there Jocelyn that tonight's gonna be
a little weird weird show for me because
my four-year-old daughter's nursery
school teacher is here tonight oh really
I have a lovely charming tiny little
four-year-old girl named Olivia and
she's the light of my life and she's a
beautiful sweet kid and she goes to this
great school and they've got an amazing
staff of people there it turns out one
of the the teachers there Jocelyn Dwyer
is a fan and she wanted to come see the
show tonight and I said sure come on out
and I got comped her tickets you know I
wanted her enjoy yourself and then it
dawned on me as I was driving here
tonight I'm a filthy Pig I'm a horrible
human being who really just just gets
down in the in the in the muck and the
mire and rolls around in it and I I say
horrible horrible things on a weekly
basis here in a morning is gonna be a
series of do you know what your dad said
well that's my fear is that child
services gonna come knocking on my door
and they're gonna say yes we got a
report mr. Garmin that a concerned party
was witness to something you did over
the weekend and we don't think your
daughter should be in your care any
longer really so do you have to promise
whatever happens tonight stays between
us all right
all right fair enough okay if I was you
man I'd rethink my [ __ ] school if a
teacher comes to this show profile' her
well if she doesn't talk about me let's
talk about hers you come solo or did you
come with somebody Oh a very
non-committal some friends
could you imagine if you got your
[ __ ] kids preschool teacher laid
tonight
all right now they'll be none of that
this is all this is all going into an
area I'm not comfortable with quite
frankly anybody out there wanna get talk
stop it
that woman is a saint and my daughter's
an angel and let's just leave it be fair
enough fair enough
just sayin I I'm gonna feel a little
self-conscious tonight with Mike with
Mike yeah Ryan it in I'm gonna ring we
started off going balls deep yeah you
were like I'm going full Ralph and now
I'll let you know what I'm reading it
yeah be in the lab and like assless
chaps you know working that petri dish
did you hear that stop it you will not
address my daughters Jocelyn name is
wire miss Dwyer mr. wire they do they do
the last name their school yes right huh
[ __ ] hippie school did your kid go to
yeah what's up miss Betty how you doing
sexy cab helped him make some new
friends and potentially get him laid
here in the city Evangeline Joe have you
met miss Dwyer
I'm I wasn't your teacher can you reach
me for me there's no nothing more erotic
than a shaper of young minds
taking herbal household I'm so sorry I
just for a stranger from out of town
I apologize Joe from Chicago needs an
education miss Dwyer won't you give him
a star supposed to talk to him oh why
why would i seduce him the first guy you
haven't tried to seduce well the whole
time we've been doing this bit to hook
him up he's single he's looking oh she's
gonna be pissed now she's gonna beat my
kid now if that's what's gonna happen
what do you mean porn softcore or flat
out like stop it is there a category
preschool teacher porn no and there will
never be I'm taking out my ruler uh-huh
big bucket a win he will be missed
don't divide your kids teacher to
[ __ ] shows in the future man I
learned I used to invite my mother the
show and then I'd be like ah ha Cox I
can't say
[Music]